[Music]
just see those few moments of my life
seconds of my life i both laugh i almost
cry my palms are sweaty watching it
i'd lied to say that i went without a
thought that
maybe it would come to me but it was a
pretty illustrious
crew of women i was nominated with
so there was no assumption and oscar
for supporting access goes to
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
there's really something about that
theater
and that audience you look out in the
first
four or five rows you've known every
face
that you're seeing there to share the
stage with
kirk douglas is incredibly moving to me
you pinch me
mine very genuinely unexpected
not the wind so much but what the
experience itself
was oh wow
really really really really really truly
wow
i know there's a lot of people that said
a lot of real real nice things to me
for several months now
but i'm just shaking in my boots here to
work opposite christian bale
and mark robert without mark wahlberg we
went out a movie
you know and if i could have remembered
all the names of all the crew
that's how we do what we do first and
foremost
thank you academy because it's about
selling motion pictures
and respecting the work thank you
so much
to go back and look at it it really
reminds me what a
turning point in my life it was and a
turning point
in ways that yeah you think you know
what i'm saying
but you don't know what i'm saying it's
so deep inside of me
and that is the most special part of it
something that nobody else will ever
understand
except perhaps another academy award
you